and thanks to all of you for attending
the talk as Rob said I have a background
in international agreements but since
there isn't all that much happening in
that field I thought it might be
interesting to look at if countries are
themselves achieving something a little
more ambitious in this field and mostly
by accident I ended up doing this work
in India a good friend of mine had a
research institute in Delhi and I
emailed him and he told me that there's
a lot of interesting things happening in
India right now and I got addicted to
the country not only the food but also
these topics and today's talk I'm going
to talk about the role of renewable
energy in India and the background for
this this research is is India's energy
poverty problem so if you look at the
india's current situation the country's
population is about 1.2 billion people
and it's one of these emerging economies
but it's still considerably more poor
than for example Brazil or China and in
the energy field this manifests itself
in there being about 400 million people
who don't have access to basic household
electricity so every third Indian
doesn't have electricity at all this
doesn't mean that there hasn't been any
progress this is an improvement in 2001
the census of india tells us that they
were fifty five percent of the
population who had electricity it's
increased to 67 so this is goodness okay
however the bad news is that the
remaining reading population doesn't
have a good solution most of them use
kerosene lamps which are problematic for
various reasons there are a health risk
their environmental problem they are a
safety hazard and they don't provide
good lighting so this is a big problem
it has real consequences for these
people's livelihoods of the economy of
India Rural Development solar power has
started to make some progress in India
but if you look at the latest census
numbers it's still not making a big tent
there's about half a percent of Indians
who use solar power as their primary
mode of lighting so these are most
the solar home systems that you install
on your rooftop okay on the cooking side
which I'm not going to talk about all
that much my focus today is mostly on
electricity the cook inside the problem
is equally serious they're about 800
million Indians who still rely on
traditional biomass and mostly in using
very inefficient cooking technologies
which creates indoor air pollution means
that use a lot of time collecting
firewood there's a better way to do this
but in India unfortunately there hasn't
been all that much progress in solving
the problem in terms of India's
geographic distribution is also notable
that this problem is centered around its
northern and eastern parts of India so
if you look at this map you can see that
the south of India is doing pretty well
most of these areas have achieved 95%
91st and electrification rates the West
is also doing reasonably well eighty
percent ninety percent some reason
success stories for example rajasthan
has improved dramatically or the past
ten years in the east though we have a
prawn india's biggest status with the
pradesh with the population of 200
million people and there you can see
less than one half of the population has
electricity at home in bihar which is a
population of 100 million people the
person which is about twenty percent
today so this is a this is a critical
situation it's a it's a it's a serious
problem in Bihar there you can see some
progress now the government has made
quite a pure progress in improving this
in Uttar Pradesh much less so so so
sadly the biggest state of India is the
one where the governance of the energy
sector is one of the worst okay and this
motivates my research this is where if
we can look at which renewable energy
and see available its potential it could
have significant implications for
hundreds of millions of people so this
is a real policy issue that I think
requires a tracing and there's quite a
bit of going on but I haven't seen a lot
of good evaluation of the possible
strategies and alternatives and whether
they are economically feasible
politically feasible and whether we
could use them to make a big effect okay
and that's what I'm trying to
evaluated a based on several years of
research in India I'm trying to see what
would be some practical next steps for
India in the short run and then would
would be a viable long-term strategy for
solving this problem okay now this if
you want to understand energy poverty
and if you want to address it we
obviously need to start with the
question well why why is there energy
policy and if you think of the case of
electricity which again is today's topic
the first obvious reason is that India
is a big country it's a lot of villages
some of them are very far removed from
towns and industrial centers so that
means that connecting them though the
electricity grid is going to cost a lot
of money so one of the things with grid
electrification is that is fairly easy
to do if you happen to have the grid
close by and in fact if you look at
India you can see in the 1950s 60s and
70s very fast progress in rural
electrification simply because there
were a lot of villages around towns
towns are easy to electrify it's a cost
effective measure because there are lot
of people to consume that power if you
happen to have a village within a few
miles why not it's not that expensive
but now we've reached the point where
many of these villages can be miles and
miles from the closest power line
extending the grid can be quite
expensive but that's only one reason
because we have a similar situation in
many other countries in China they also
remote villages but all of them have
power in the u.s. there are many more
well I'm sure if I would call them
villages but their towns that are very
far from everything all of them have
power okay but India doesn't have and
one of the reasons is that the power
sector in India has for a long time
suffered from from various problems the
fundamental one being the lack of
investment in generation and
infrastructure so in India there is a
persistent gap between the supply of
power and the demand for power and if
you don't build power plants if you
don't extend the grid you won't be able
to shrink the gap and the reasons behind
this are mostly on the government side
so India under prices electricity many
farmers in many states get free
electricity which means that if you are
a state electricity board you don't have
any revenue you could use to actually
build power plant
if you are the role electrification
corporation you don't have the finances
to extend the grid and even if you have
the finances to extend the grid you will
extend the grid but nobody's supplying
power to the grid and having a power
line itself is not useful unless there
is some actual current flowing through
it right so India faces many problems
now these problems in principle you
could solve through some reforms in the
power sector and in fact or at the end
of my talk I'm going to Plame that that
in the long run is the best way to go
for India but at the same time we face
the short-term issue of 400 million
people without electricity is there
something we can do to solve this
problem now without waiting for the very
long slow political process that could
solve the power sector so I have talked
about the power sector extensively with
many of my good friends who live in
India we've been working on the power
sector for decades and they're all very
pessimistic about the possibility of a
short-term solution this very difficult
political problem the only engineering
side I think we agree everybody agrees
what needs to be done but on the
political side it is very hot because
you have to raise power prices and there
are some groups there are some
constituency's that benefit from the low
prices okay in particular some of these
large farmers were able to pump water
out of the ground using cheap power for
them the fact that the power is not
reliable it's not so important because
for them what matters is how much you
get over 24 hours when you get it it's
not so important because for a family
who is trying to use electricity to
provide lighting services may be a fan
mobile charging in modern households
also cooking which is not so common in
India so far you need the power when
you're at home which is at night when
it's never available because that's
actually the peak time of the Indian
Industry so this is a very difficult
problem and it has very severe
consequences for the quality of life
imagine yourself if you had to live
without electricity for a long period of
time I live in New Jersey Oh little live
there last year when I was on leave at
Princeton and I was one of the victims
of Sandy hours without electricity for a
while and yeah it was tough okay so
so what can we do that well as I said
one of the solutions that is prone one
of the sort of natural solutions is
great extension that's the way this
problem is solved in all of the
industrialized countries so if you go to
the US in the 1930s you had these big
New Deal projects where the grid was
extended through funding from the
agriculture of the local cooperatives in
these these towns and that solution
proved to be very effective it also
turned out that even though in the short
run a that very little effect on for
example productivity of agriculture in
the long run it allowed this remarkable
transformation where you started having
industry in terms that never had any in
the past so it became very important the
alternative solution of electrification
is this idea of distributed energy
generation so this is the idea that
instead of connecting these villages to
the grid you built this kind of mini
power plants within the villages so for
example the kind of extreme example of
disability energy generation is a solar
Lantern so I could have this lantern
that I charge during the day using
sunlight and then at night I get a few
hours of light and that's nice for some
uses it's not exactly a convenient
modern solution because it's just one
Lantern I have to remember to go and
always charge it during the day and so
on then there is a solar home system
where I put those solar panels on my
roof top that generates electricity
charges it automatically during the day
and I use that at night for lighting and
other purposes that's another solution
it's also very distributed then there's
a third solution which is the idea of a
micro grid so it's as though I'm
building a small electric grid within a
village I have a small local power plant
which in this case could mean a few
solar panels and a battery and then I
draw transmission wires from that power
plant two different households they pay
a monthly fee for their electricity and
they get the service in exchange and I'm
going to spend quite a bit of time
talking about that because based on what
I've seen in the field this solution
seems to have many desirable features
that some of the others don't okay on
the cooking side i just want to mention
this briefly so that you don't get the
impression that i'm ignoring this other
problem which in many ways
equally serious maybe even more in India
traditional biomass is being replaced by
LPG so liquefied petroleum gas fairly
common in the cities now in some many
cities is the most common thing it's a
little expensive for most of these
households is not the sort of jeepers
thing to do but if you're a middle-class
household it's pretty convenient so one
of my students works for the Mahindra in
Bombay and his solution was LPG he
doesn't have an electric stove because
this turned out to be a lot more
effective and his middle class if any
way the other solution then is this
improved cookstoves which are kind of a
second best solution where you still
continue to rely on biomass and you have
to worry about collecting the firewood
and all that but at least you can try to
improve the efficiency of the burning so
that you'll have less L indoor air
pollution you'll have less time spent
collecting the firewood and so on ok so
this is another solution that you see in
there in the cooking space rub is a lot
more qualified to talk about these
solutions then I am so I'm going to
focus on the electricity in this period
of comparative advantage ok so why
renewable energy why are we talking
about renewable energy today in there in
the sort of grand scheme of things if
you go back just 10 20 years there
wasn't a lot of interest in this there
were a few kind of enthusiasts there
were these people who believed in in
this being a democratic way of
generating energy and getting rid of the
oppression of the local electricity
boards but it was a very small kind of
marginal fringe community and there was
very little interest in this by policy
makers and the reason was that it was
very expensive but over the past 20
years we have seen a fairly drastic
decrease in the cost of renewable energy
generation so wind power has become a
lot less expensive than it used to this
day still in most places it's more
expensive than for example call but the
difference is not all that week and if
you haven't been a nice windy area like
a North Dakota or something then
generating electricity for the local
area from wind might actually be your
best solution Solar even more drastic
story just five years ago people mostly
ignored it it was kind of a thought
that's an incredibly expensive solution
but
now with traumatic decreases in the cost
of solar panels batteries inverters and
so on mostly thanks to Chinese
manufacturing at a very large scale the
cost of solar has come down and for
India this is particularly important
India is not from the wind perspective
it's not necessarily the ideal country
when you're in India and it's 115
decrease you wish in they had a little
more wind it unfortunately often doesn't
but India in terms of Sun is doing very
well and the reason is that even though
often when you are in India you feel
like the Sun is there but it doesn't
feel that bright because of that kind of
haze that you see it turns out that for
solar electricity it doesn't matter the
intensity of the Sun what matters is
that is consistently available and if
anything in India it is consistently
available you have the monsoon season
but outside that it's sunshine all the
time okay in many areas of India
including actually bihar andhra pradesh
where this problem is its largest and as
a result Solar has a lot of power
biomass you can use it in better ways
than just collecting wood and burnin it
you can use for example many or you can
use in biomass cook stoves all kinds of
ways to do that small hydro electricity
so you can use the small rivers you have
these new technologies that allow you to
generate electricity for much more love
flows than in the past when the only
solution was this large hydro electric
facilities is big dams that India
actually has quite a few neferu India's
first prime minister called them the
modern temples he was very excited about
a large hydro but that potential is
mostly being used now all that we have
left are the small rivers the other
thing is that this is the reason why I'm
interested in the summer political
scientists and we don't need powers
activate form so i think the power
sector requires our attention and in
India should do a lot more to reform it
I think their efforts should be
intensified but it is a very hard
problem whereas you can start an
electrified villages using solar power
without any power sector reform the
legislation in India the regulations
don't prevent anybody from going to a
village and providing electricity they
make it very hard for you to build power
plants and throw power lines and
selective tariffs that's very difficult
but decentralized generation you can
just go to a village and start doing it
okay so that's why it's a kind of fun
nice short term solutions that you can
do without so big changes at the
national level yes sir so with smart
quits it depends on what kind of
technology were using so there's some
very simple ones that provide basic
services like lighting a mobile judge
you no need for a smart with all you
need to do is is it up a basic DC system
and that's it if you want to have a
prepaid real-time monitoring system then
you might want to have a smart good even
in a village but as I will argue soon
I'm not optimistic about that because of
the high costs now India has in the past
seven or eight years has done something
impressive this is the rajiv gandhi
Grameen V duty Karan yojana scheme my
Hindi is pretty terrible but basically
this is the rajiv gandhi rural
electrification scheme where the idea is
to bring electricity to everybody in
india and in the past 78 years they've
managed to electrify more than 100,000
villages this is really impressive India
has about six and seven hundred thousand
villages depending on how you count and
they've managed to electrify another one
sixth of them so they're actually pretty
close to having a ninety to ninety-five
percent village electrification rate
there are two problems with this the
first one is that again having the power
line does not help if there is no
current flowing through okay so you do
need power the line itself is not enough
the second problem is that within each
village electrification is defined today
I think as a ten percent of the
households having a connection and at
least one below poverty line household
having a connection so ten percent is
not a lot so this could mean that all
the villages have power but nobody in
the villages actually has any power okay
so this is one possibility and in fact
in some cases I actually think this is a
pretty good scheme and I'm impressed
with how much they've achieved but there
have been cases where you go to a
village that is supposed to be
electrified and and there's nothing
inside you cannot see a single power
line within my sort of miles and miles
okay so there are some cases where the
bureaucrats kind of cooked the books to
meet the targets
because the targets are defined as how
many villages you Electrify that's how
your salary and your promotions they
depend on how many village is not
whether you actually manage to provide
electricity but this scheme also
actually uses renewable energy and
distributed generation so there's about
three thousand villages I think that the
government of india has managed to
electrify using solar wind hydro and so
on so they do do this to some extent not
as much as they do using grid extension
because this is limited to the remote
area so there is some formula I don't
know exactly how it works that sort of
determines whether a village is quality
eligible or whether it qualifies for its
kind of distributed energy generation if
it does if it's for example a tribal
village in the middle of a forest then
they will go there and provide
electricity using this system okay I'm
not going to talk so much about that
it's a government-led scheme I'm going
to talk a little more about private
sector solutions which I think have some
advantages they of course have some down
sides which is for example that they
depend on profitability you cannot use
it as a kind of a social service
provision they have the advantage to pay
depend on profits people tend to be
motivated by money more than pretty much
any other thing maybe love is the other
X equal importing and as a result if you
can get a private sector industry going
and if you can make money by providing
electricity to these people then it will
probably be a sustainable in the long
run system because a government scheme
depends on political incentives and
electoral coalition's and so on so the
private sector solution has some some
benefits that I will talk about in a
second ok so I've already mentioned to
you this yes yes so they the funding for
these programs comes from from two
places one is the Planning Commission so
that the highest level the central
government puts in billions and billions
of rupees to fund this and then the
state's chip in from their own rural
electrification boards so the India's
rural electrification structure in
general is that you have the central
allocation and then you have the state
each state of India has its own board
well the utilities are mostly publicly
owned so impressive or some of this
money could come from the utilities but
most of them are bankrupt so it will
have to come from a separate subsidy in
principle the utilities are supposed to
do this but they don't have the money so
they so they have to use some other tax
revenue tool to do this so so this
technology so I've sort of looked at all
of these I'm looking at all three and
I've seen the companies and they've
given me the sales pitch and I've seen
the people who use them and I'm actually
doing some experience right try to sell
some of these things in India but my own
view of these is that the solar lanterns
that's it that's a kind of fun it's not
even a second best in terms of ecology
the third best solution it's it's really
not a replacement for lighting its solar
lanterns are useful for some specific
things so if you at night want to go
outside and you want to make sure that
there are no snakes around a solar
lantern is great for that okay or if you
have kids who need to study a soul
answer might be enough if you want to
have a household where you can do things
like who can read fairly conveniently
without spending all of your time
worrying about lighting solar lanterns
are generally not a very good solution
so people when you try to sell solar
lanterns to these villagers they often
just don't want to buy them they say
that if you give it to me for free i'll
take it but i wouldn't pay a fifty
rupees for that because it really isn't
that useful for me so the solar lanterns
are not something that the quality and
the sort of size of their the magnitude
of the service is so small that it's
almost like insulting somebody there's
not really a big difference between them
and cursing yeah so let's so let's so
they so so traditionally they lead acid
batteries I think now with their with
the solar lanterns you have more at
Wesley human solutions and all kinds of
things that charging is in most systems
they now have their own small solar
panel attached to the lunch and so you
put it outside during the day bring it
back if you charge for eight hours you
get maybe four to six hours of power for
this solar home systems are I think more
interesting they are fairly popular in
India now
there are millions and millions of
people who use them and their businesses
that the growing cellco is the most
famous for selling this there now many
others I have a good friend who runs one
of these businesses in Delhi the problem
with the solar home systems is that it
require requires today that general it
requires an upfront payment it's hard to
arrange a financial arrangement where
you would lease it because the
microcredit revolution is not as
advanced in India's it for example in
Bangladesh ok and that means then that
people have to have some disposable
income and if you go to a typical
household that doesn't have electricity
they're generally very poor so if you
ask them to pay twelve thousand rupees
which is about two hundred dollars today
that's a lot of money it really is a lot
of money which means that you see the
solar home systems on the rooftops of
developing people so I went to some
villages where most people had no
electricity at all and then I heard that
this is one guy who has it and I went to
his house he had this because he had you
know his TV he hadn't interfered
computer so he had really managed to do
everything it turns out I think that his
son was a policeman which in India is a
very lucrative profession not because of
the salary but because of some other
reasons and so as a result the solar
home systems are useful but they are not
a great solution for the median villager
in a poor relation interpretation these
are for their rural middle class so to
say okay people whose lives kind of
resemble hours but are a little more
basic but these are not desperately for
people ok solar micro grids are nice
because they have this one great
advantage which is that what you're
providing is a service so you're not
selling anything to anybody you set up a
micro video and you say that I'll draw a
connection to your house provided that
you pay me let's say 100 rupees a month
ok and it turns out that even though
over time this obviously adds up I mean
you have to pay and it is a significant
expense generally these households are
able in most of these villages they are
able to find money to do that if they
care about lighting which in my
experience they overwhelmingly do they
will be able to find 100 rupees a month
it's not a problem and if you make a
critical kind of contract where you
simply say as long as the money comes in
you get lighting if the money goes away
you don't get lighting it's a very
simple deal
it doesn't require any complex
transactions this is the way you do it
as long as you have qualified staff
there which itself is of course a
challenge if you can do it that way then
this will solve the prawn so the micro
grids have the nice benefit that if you
set up one you can get the electricity
to you know 40 households and you do it
as a service instead of trying to sell
an expensive acid the problem of course
is that you need to have somebody in the
field to maintain the micro pretend the
business case study that I'll show you
in a in a few minutes we all basically
going to provide you an idea of how you
could do this so so the business I want
to talk about this is called mera girl
power so my village power marigot is
Hindi for my village and this is a
business set up by two Americans another
one of them is actually in the element
that one of them is ethnically Indian
but he was born in Montana and this is
speak a single word of Hindi so they set
up a company a few years ago in and they
operate in Uttar Pradesh they're very
business savvy day instead of doing what
the world bank tells them or what the
International Finance Corporation tells
them go to some random country and run a
program for us they focus their business
they are another Pradesh that's where
the business is that's where the clients
are that's where the actions so I think
I like that a lot they provide a very
simple service so a household in a
village can I get connected to the micro
quit if they and get to LED lights as
part of the package and a mobile charger
these are the tool by far the most
popular kind of low electricity services
the people comment first I want lighting
once they get it get it they start
asking for mobile charging okay then the
next things would be fan a fan but
that's a lot more power so that's
difficult arrange these two are easy
okay and this is what they get and they
pay about two dollars a month so you
know 100 rupees hundred twenty rupees
the exchange rate has been going up and
down so it's a little difficult to pin
this down but it's in that ballpark and
as long as they keep making the payment
they get electricity every night the
lights go on around 6pm there's really
no need for them before that in in that
area and they stay on till 10 11
pm you can only use the power to power
these devices you cannot use it to to do
other things because otherwise that
would be too much demand for power ok
installation costs according to mariga's
website is 800 to 1000 dollars or fifty
sixty thousand rupees covers 30 to 40
households so this is what I like about
this it's only twenty dollars
twenty-five dollars a household that's
not a lot I mean if you think of we have
400 million households so you could in
principle install all this you could do
all this at about 10 billion dollars 400
million sorry I'm 400 million people
means 80 million households two billion
dollars everybody in India would have
access to electricity that's not a lot
obviously they would then have to pay
the monthly fees and all that but in
terms of the investment this is not a
big this is no vacation that's why I
find this solution attractive it can be
done we don't need to get into this
debate whether the West provides 200
billion 300 billion 500 billion dollars
we have all the money we can just go and
do it okay it's more expensive so per
unit of electricity and we are talking
about what's not kilowatts it's a really
small amounts of power you pay a lot
maybe ten times as much as you pay would
pay for creed ii electricity and that of
course has created some controversy
there are some NGOs that complain about
this an exploitation they call it
because these people pay more than my
middle class friends in in Delhi pay for
the electricity but at the same time the
total payment is not outrageous and the
alternative is kerosene so I think from
a practical perspective I see a lot of
virtue in this solution I would love to
live in a world where everybody has 24 7
electricity nicely available we don't
live in that world we need to do
something I would rather have
electricity than kerosene that's my view
of this ok most households can afford is
not everybody there are some of the very
poorest landless sort of Labor
households might not be able to afford
this this would be too much for them
most households if they value the
service they will be able to so if you
have a typical household with let's say
you know parents and three to four kids
they have some schooling face there on a
bit of land
they farm they have a small side
business maybe they you know bake
something for the street sweet side
sales maybe they decorate some sorry is
big enough for this and in fact they can
make a bit of money if they improve
their lighting there sorry is that they
decorate become more beautiful instead
of selling the lock now they will sell
it so the Bombay Bombay saris you pay a
lot more than you pay like now you make
more money so you see some small
business activity coming out of this
it's another nice nice feature know that
I don't want to over emphasize this it's
not like they start factories or
anything but there is some activity that
would otherwise be difficult because
getting good lighting from a tradition
or going to battery charged light is
very expensive this is a lot cheaper
than that so here we go this is some
deep good friend of mine some deep lives
in in Uttar Pradesh and he works for
mega power this is one of their systems
the nice thing about the systems reason
is very simple you have solar panels
here you have a battery I don't think
you can even see this probably back
there and then you have the lines going
you can't even see them unfortunately
but they would be going from one
household that agrees to take the system
the others one thing that was sort of
weird and for those who study climate
change this is in January this is not
supposed to happen we're not supposed to
have monsoon in January but when i was
there in last January they had what they
call the winter monsoon which last time
it happened was in 1947 it destroyed all
the crops so climate change is a real
problem for these people I I know of
people in that area who went to meetings
in other villages by boat where there
previously had used their bike okay so
this was a this is a big problem and it
also makes actually electricity really
difficult because monsoon first of all
means that there's not that much Sun
Shine and the other thing is that since
everything is very wet the systems can
get compromised and all that so that's a
challenge climate changes all kinds of
effects we cannot always n sip it now so
why why this as I said I one of the
reasons is this lack of need for a
financing solution you just make a
monthly payment so this is something
that households can can fairly easy to
do you can get some small household
business so some example
as I said one of them is this roadside
wending so so for example there was this
one woman who got a better lighting
solution she decided to start baking she
went to the closest road and she set up
this little shop there India's is full
of these and sell some samosas and
pakoras and so on and she makes a bit
more money with that okay and it's her
own money so her husband's money which
is also a big deal in in this areas
where gender kind of power is very
asymmetric livestock handling I've also
heard of cases where people use solar
power to take care of their cattle at
night which previously was not possible
you need to see if the animals seeker if
there's something wrong with some parts
of its body or something this allows
them to do so that's another advantage
the quality of light thing as i said is
better cost is generally lower kerosene
even though it's subsidized the subsidy
is only given to a small amount of
kerosene pretty much nobody has enough
of the subsidized kind the private
market kind is three or four times as
expensive you have to go and find
somebody who wants to sell to you it's
it's a mess so that's a solar lighting
is better in that sense health and
safety issues so one of the things that
struck me when I went to these villages
and I didn't have a lot of experience
with everyday life there was how many
people were victims of kerosene fires so
even when I started talking to them
about lighting I thought they would be
interested in the quality of the
lighting in the health the smoke all
that they were talking about kerosene
fires they said in 1997 you know my
mother got burned because of this and
she still aching because of burns so
this is a big problem calcium is very
dangerous especially when you burn it in
this kind of very primitive lamps that
don't have any kind of safeguards if
something goes wrong you'll have a fire
okay Solar doesn't have that problem so
that has some nice things one final
thing that's the 30 couple about this
this business model said it doesn't
require any subsidies so the government
doesn't give a penny do this okay so
it's a purely this two dollars a month
is the market for it this is what you
pay without any government subsidy so if
the government wanted to provide a kind
of a simple subsidy that the below
poverty line households would get a low
a solution they could do it very easily
and bring the cost down from two dollars
to one dollar okay but none of that is
necessary to bring electricity to most
households they're all this can be done
as a regular business transaction which
i think is useful because in the long
run it means again sustainability solar
is sustainable environmentally but also
sustainability in terms of the business
is it doesn't depend on what somebody
decides in Delhi it will be a solution
that as long as the cost of the system
doesn't go up it is a good business okay
yes I think we are talking about just a
few watts of charge but the whole thing
is based on this idea that today a
mobile charger basically conceived
nothing one watt or something that's
their power and the same with these LED
lights it's just a few words maybe you
know eight nine what's something that is
enough okay to give this appliance is
going and that's why this is a good
business as soon as you go to 100 watt
or something all this becomes really
difficult to sustain in these villages
so a limitation so I don't want to sell
snake oil I don't want to sell that this
is this is going to be the final
solution that will solve all problems
with this system so one thing the
so-called productive loads I don't
really like the term because I think
sorry declaration is productive but this
idea that you would for example power a
water pump for agriculture this is not
possible with a system like this it's
also not possible to power a some girl
from agricultural system like a treasure
it's not possible grinding grain it's a
possible and so on a small factory so it
can happen okay so this is a limited
solution for a very specific need which
is household lighting mobile charging a
small places okay that's it so the cost
of doing this would be a lot more higher
so I know some companies that do this
they require investments of tens of
thousands of dollars per village so the
hundreds and hundreds of dollars per
household that's a lot
it could be profitable if there was a
kind of already business proposal there
in some cases there are but often you
kind of wonder that if there is a great
business waiting for you maybe the money
would have come from somewhere else
maybe they would have just bought a
diesel pump why do you need solar ok so
my sort of skepticism of this is that
currently these are productive loads
they depend on subsidies you need a very
kind of heavy subsidy by the government
to make this work it's not the case that
if you provide solar power these
villages become this kind of dynamic
power houses that grow at you know
twenty five percent a year it's not that
simple there are many other problems in
these villages for their economic growth
as an irrigation industry possible and
here i think that the sort of
distributive aspects become a little
more important so I'm sort of willing to
take the idea that if people have to pay
a high cost per unit but a few units I'm
okay with that if it provides a good
service but if they have to buy a lot of
units and pay a very high price for them
that to me seems unfair and at that
point i would start wondering if you're
investing tens of thousands of dollars
per village why not just draw the line
and and solve the problem that way okay
so this is not a I think this is the
kind of solution the proactive loads
these big solar panels really big system
smart creates prepaids of that they will
at some point begin to play a role but I
think it's going to take a while I don't
think we are there yet where's the
household lighting system it's it's
already feasible and useful so what
about policy so the first thing is the
bad news so I'm skeptical of this idea
of leapfrogging I don't think this
disability energy generation is a
solution in the sense that we won't have
this we won't have you know projectors
and computers and nice lighting and
heating and AC that's not going to
happen through these sort of things I
think it's just much too expensive for
pro country like India you go to
sub-saharan Africa where the
electrification rates or even lower it's
even worse okay so i don't think i think
power sector reform is ultimately the
only way to really provide get a modern
quality of life
these people I don't see any any way out
of that at least right now maybe 30
years from now there are some fantastic
technologies that provide electricity
out of air or something but today we
still live in a world where power plants
are the main thing to go however at the
same time this off-grid electrification
has the potential to solve one of our
problems which is household electricity
I think there we could make real
progress so I know from facebook from
mega power I know that their record so
far is 13 villages in one day okay and
this is a small company two guys a local
partner imagine if Tata or some other
big company bought their business model
and did the same thing I think they
could do a thousand villages add a
fairly easy maybe I'm a bit optimistic
but still even if they could only do one
hundredth day it's a lot of villages per
year okay so this is something that
really really good in the short run
provide relief and provide a basic
service that I think many people in
these villages would value while at the
same time the government continues this
kind of uphill struggle to fix the power
sector so so this is something I don't
think this will change the world I don't
think this will change India solve all
its prawns but I think it solves one
problem in a cost-effective way and most
importantly we can do it today ok so I
think it has a role playing in bed and
in fact one of the things I'm trying to
do right now I'm still don't have the
funding for this but hopefully one day I
would actually do an evaluation of
America powers business model and when I
say evaluation I think to me it's enough
that these pieces make sense if people
want it so we don't want to be
patronizing if it will eat just one good
lighting then that's what they'll get I
think that's enough I'm happy about this
even if I don't find us any kind of a
development effect but I do believe
there's some hope for things like small
business activity improved schooling
maybe because of better lighting and so
on that would be nice additions if
having those would be great that's not
why I villages by these things they buy
them because they want to have good
lighting but if we in addition get some
sort of transformative or socio-economic
development I think that would be great
and I'm hoping that we can do an
evaluation a kind of a randomized
control trial to see if these micro
grids
make make make a difference the big
challenge here of course being that we
are looking at a cheap solution that
produces small effects so doing that in
a kind of systematic way capturing the
effects is going to be a challenge but
we are trying to do it okay and so so
what would I then recommend I I don't
want to recommend too much many things I
don't know i'm not i haven't spent
decades working on the indian power
sector but i do have a few sort of
faults i'm pretty confident about and
the first one here is that this off-grid
electrification does have good potential
and I think these states that suffer
from low electrification rates oup bihar
or Asia and Jharkhand in particular come
to mind I think they should make a
concentrated effort to promote the
system they should not try to invest in
these really complicated and expensive
systems they should not design any
complicated subsidy schemes just create
an environment where these private
entrepreneurs can do their business
while making sure that there's enough
regulation that it doesn't turn into
exploitation and I think that would
itself be enough okay but unfortunately
some of these states what's of relations
really made a priority out of this I
think they should at the same time I
mean I think productive loads are a good
idea and it's good that we have these
experimental projects it's good that we
have demonstration commercialization but
we need to treat them as such we should
not get kind of carried away with the
idea that we are going to go and provide
this really big solar power plants to
fifty thousand villages in the next five
years or something I don't think that's
going to happen and if it happens then
it's an outrageous waste of resources it
should have been used for something else
so as a result I think that it should be
treated as a kind of an early stage
technology that needs to be supported
but we need to be patient let's think of
10 20 years not three or five okay for
this product it was and then finally
power sector reform again as I said I
really hope that the solar doesn't
become an alternative I think hope it
will be a compliment and the way I see
this is I would hope that the pricing
would be a little more rational this is
a really tough part okay so getting
farmers who right now get electricity
for free in Andhra Pradesh getting them
to pay for it it's not going to be easy
because they've been having the free
service for our
almost 10 years now improved revenue
collection so I don't know if metering
is the best way or if you fixed rate
better sort of monitoring I think the
power sector people are more qualified
than I am to tell you how to do this but
I do think that this is an important of
priority increase the investment in
generation this is ultimately the one of
the big problems Indiana is to invest a
lot more in in power generation and
distributed energy should not be seen as
I said probably ten times by now should
not be seen as an alternative it's a
compliment that these two things that
provide different solutions one solves
the household problem in the short run
the other one has the potential for
solving the bigger problem in the long
run and there's no contradiction between
pursuing both as long as it doesn't have
been that one of them is used as a
diversion so you say that all I'm
interesting you know this sort of things
so no need for power sector reform I
think that would be the worst possible
outcome to come out of this okay and I
guess that's it so just to highlight my
message one more time so solar power
which I've used as an example I we can
talk about hydro and so on if you want
has potential for solving a real problem
in the short run but it's a small
problem we should not ignore the fact
that there is a bigger problem that will
require power sector reform and India I
don't think has any way out of this i
think they are either going to have to
be satisfied with remaining and largely
an electrified country or alternatively
they're going to have to fix this policy
problem thank you for your attention